hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapters two and six of tragic sense
of life you'll see miguel de una muno
bringing descartes up rene descartes the
great
17th century early modern rationalist
philosopher
some would actually call him one of the
fathers of modern western philosophy
even of modernity you're going to see
miguel de una muno bringing descartes
up and criticizing a
kind of mistake that he thinks descartes
made
in how he's doing philosophy and
descartes is not unique
in this there's others that unemono is
criticizing as well
but the cartesian mistake is one that's
particularly
emblematic and by looking at unamuno's
argument here his criticisms here
his what he's preferring to us in place
of what descartes
is providing we can learn more about
unemuno's own
perspective and it is good to call it
the cartesian mistake
and not simply the mistake of rene
descartes
because of the very nature of
what's happening there descartes thought
that you could reduce
philosophy in effect to a method
and then results of that method
that he was putting into place and
providing us in the discourse on method
and then showing us applied in the
meditations on first
philosophy and cartesian
uh approaches in philosophy the the
method that descartes is using
there's a big mistake involved there
according to unemuno and this
is a as he calls it a resolution to
begin
by emptying himself of himself and here
we could actually pause
for just a moment because when we see
that language of emptying
there's a lot of people who influenced
by other philosophical movements of
people well that's really great
man you should empty yourself of ego you
know
you should be as objective as possible
and try to think
as if you were like the the person who
isn't really a person who's
all people right empty yourself of all
of these
previous experiences and assumptions
that's so wonderful
and una muno would say no that's a
terrible idea i mean
you can do that if you want to that is a
possibility for human beings
that's a great way to generate bad
philosophy
descartes is sort of like good bad
philosophy according to una muno
he's he's certainly worth reading but
he's making a fundamental error
and so he tells us that the defect of
descartes discourse of method
is not in the antecedent methodological
doubt not in beginning
by resolving to doubt everything but in
his resolution about how he's doing this
to begin by emptying himself of himself
of descartes
of the real man the man of flesh and
bone
the man who does not want to die in
order that he may be a
mere thinker that is an abstraction
now isn't that an interesting idea
descartes
is probably you know doing exactly that
we don't know exactly what was in his
head as he was writing these things
because what we have is descartes the
writer not descartes the person
you know uh engaging in the writing the
meditations the
you could call it the character of the
meditations is not
rene descartes himself we don't know
that these meditations
are precisely what he went through in
the stove heated room
in germany during the 30 years war while
he was in winter quarters we have a
presentation
and a presentation that is in the first
person
and is leading us along inviting us to
join in
on the journey and the more that we can
abstract away from ourselves
the more we can participate in this this
journey and follow along
so there's kind of an interesting
tension
here and unum actually points us out he
says descartes didn't completely succeed
in this
he couldn't keep the real man out
entirely and he references
the biographical parts of the discourse
on method where descartes talks about
you know his learning
and then how he came across the rules of
method and the provisional morality so
parts one through
three of that but even that is pretty
abstract
anybody could step into descartes
proverbial shoes right that's the way
these these
fascinating works of philosophy are
designed
and so um plays around a little bit with
this
stove heated room idea you know the the
word poe
yes it means stove descartes did not
actually
uh carry out his meditations inside of a
stove
right but it's a a room in which he's
he's in any so
he says he began to philosophize but in
germany shut up in a stove and such his
discourse is
a stove discourse and the stove is a
german one although the philosopher shut
up and it was a
frenchman and then he also says that
these doubts that that
descarte is expressing are stove doubts
a little bit later in chapter six so
this is this is something key this is
the mistake
abstracting away from who you actually
are
as a human being and not philosoph not
philosophizing from that basis
but from the basis of an imaginary
person
who is this you know every man or every
person
that the cartesian subject is supposed
to be
looking at cartesian doubt he he calls
it an intellectual
device and he tells us this is in
chapter six that descartes
degrades doubt to the function of a
method
it's part of the cartesian method it's
one of the things that that method
does it's actually you know one of the
main rules
from the discourse on method and unemuno
calls this
comic doubt what does he mean by comic
doubt does he mean it's making us laugh
no if you think about the
way in which tragedy and comedy have
been understood really
since the time of aristotle
comedy doesn't grasp what's really
essential in existence and tragedy in
some way
does if it's good tragedy comedy allows
us to laugh because
it's about bs it's about you know silly
nonsense it's about things that we take
seriously but then it turns out they
don't really matter
quite as much so here's what what um has
to say about this
this comic doubt he says that it's a
doubt purely theoretical
and provisional theoretical meaning that
it doesn't really affect our practical
life
provisional meaning that we're not going
to stay in doubt forever although we
will probably still doubt a lot of
things if we're cartesians
anything that we don't really have good
evidence for or can provide a good
argument for we're supposed to suspend
ascent that is to
to doubt but this is not the kind of
doubt that unemuno
is saying we ought to have the doubt
that is actually going to be
characteristic of the tragic
sense of life so he says because it was
a stove
excogiated doubt a doubt that was
thought out within
a stove heated room the man who deduced
that he existed from the fact that he
thought did not approve of those
turbulent and restless persons who being
called neither by birth nor fortune of
the management of public affairs
are perpetually devising some new
reformation that's in the the discourse
right
and uh he was paying by the suspicion
there might be something of this kind in
his own writings
and then unemono goes on he says no he
descarte proposed only to reform his own
thoughts
and to build upon ground that was wholly
his
so the doubt means i'm going to sweep
away
everything else and build on things that
i
myself can can learn but these aren't
going to be things from my you could say
existential condition these are only
going to be
thoughts that i could be sharing in
common with anybody else
he says he resolved not to accept
anything as true when he did not
recognize it to be clearly so
and to make a clean sweep of all
prejudices
and received ideas to the end he might
con construct his intellectual
habitation anew
and then he had a sort of provisional
ethic you know a morale the provision
and a provisional religion and even a
provisional
god and then um he says this
methodological theoretical cartesian
doubt
is not the skepticism is not the
insertitude that i'm talking about here
passionate doubt and that gets to
something you can carry out cartesian
doubt
without really feeling anything you
could do it as a pure
mind and descartes kind of presents
himself as if he's doing that
there are two important exceptions you
could say in the meditations
where these come through the the field
of similes or
likenesses or images the image of being
thrown into
deep water and being on the surface
and not knowing whether there's a bottom
to actually touch or not and then
worrying about that
worrying that you'll never arrive at
truth and then the figure of the
servant who is asleep dreaming knows
that he's dreaming
doesn't want to wake up because he knows
that the real waking world is crappier
than the nice world that he's in right
now
those you could say are expressing
something like
passionate existential doubt but those
appear for just a moment
and then we pass on in the rest of the
meditations
so cartesian doubt turns out to be
something that doesn't go
through the entire person which makes
sense because you're not philosophizing
with the entire person
and here we get to the crux of it in
looking at the cartesian
cogito descartes is very famous for
having said kojito
ergo actually he only says that at one
point there's a lot of other
formulations right
and the idea behind this is i can know
that i exist
because i think and it's not just about
i exist or i i you know i am however we
want to translate this so i'm
it's really about the kind of thing that
i am what do i discover myself as what
sort of being
am i and that means uh being a thinking
substance and so there's a reduction
of the human being to just being thought
not extension was going to talk about
that at a few other places in other
chapters saying that
this was another part of descartes
mistake distinguishing
mind and body and not finding a way to
reconnect them which descartes knew was
was a serious problem
as a matter of fact if you look at the
correspondence with princess elizabeth
of bohemia
that is one of the central issues that
they're talking about and that was
something that descartes is trying to
address
in his last big work the passions of the
soul
but unamuno is is saying
something quite interesting here and
this shows
again you could say his own existential
position
he says about descartes he arrives at
the kojito ergosome which saint
augustine had already anticipated but
the ego
implicit in this enthymeme ego cogito
ergo is an unreal that is an ideal ego
or i
and it's sum its existence something
unreal
as well that's an important point
he goes i think therefore i am can only
mean i think therefore i am a thinker
this being of the i am which is deduced
from the i think is merely a knowing
this being is knowledge but not
life there is so much more to a human
being
that descarte is not getting and you can
say well wait a second descartes talks
about
other kinds of thoughts you know and
sensations
and he does have the the passions of the
soul which he writes towards
the end of his life so isn't he
addressing this and you can say well yes
and those are examples of what uno muno
was saying the man
the the actual existentially concrete
existing human being
sort of revolts against this this
abstraction
of a ego that isn't even a real ego it's
not a real
eye it's just this this literary
theoretical device
you can say that that happens but um
it's not happening
in the meditations happening in the
discourse
and so unamuno goes on and says the
truth is
kojito i am therefore i think
although not everything that is thinks
is not consciousness of thinking above
all consciousness of being
is pure thought possible without
consciousness of self without
personality
can there exist pure knowledge without
feeling without that species of
materiality which feeling
lends to it do we not perhaps now here's
a brilliant
thing do we not perhaps
feel thoughts and do we not
feel ourselves in the act of knowing and
willing
now he he has some interesting
suggestions here
could not the man in the stove that is
descartes said i
feel therefore i am or i will
therefore i am why does
thought pure thought intellection take
priority over feeling and volition
affectivity broadly speaking that's
not just a criticism of descartes that
can be applied to pretty much
everybody who has the feeling of
intellection or
reason or whatever we're going to call
it above and separated from
all of our affective faculties
or capacities so we could have just as
well have said i feel or i will
therefore i am right
and he tells us that the primary reality
is really that i live therefore i think
we we don't think in an abstract
vacuum unless we deliberately through
thought place ourselves there
and maintain ourselves there and that he
thinks is a key aspect of this
cartesian mistake so at its bottom the
cartesian mistake
is of abstracting away from the people
that we are
and cutting ourselves off from our roots
in life
you